[Música]
Giorgia Meloni la líder de ultra Veneta
Italia que asisten a la fiesta pero
escuché que la selección de Enna se desactiva
erdomingo ocupó el Cargo della
primer ministro y primavera
la alianza Entre meloni Matteo Salvini
absolutamente mucho en el dormitorio
del parlamento que esto por supuesto
kenmas portero para cambiar el
constitución syndsesia de un consenso
su sería honesto con Giulio Levorato
estudiante de doctorado analista internacional
junto con la política y la universidad
Génova gracias al sabor era magnanie
Lunense Giulio a quien es director
Primero la simplificación
pista entre la Segunda Guerra Mundial
luego sbloccheresiana también en el camino
este incorrecto será el gobierno de Masala
Grecia que Italia tiende la era de
Mussolini ahora de la Segunda Guerra
Mundo
La consecuencia dijo mi punto
vista van a ser mas-política
políticas internas y externas
Giorgia Meloni asidua muguide rosa y
una señal de respeto digamos que son
la siciliana tradicional y es política
Exterior italiano que estoy en llamas si
en el atlantismo y
en el fuego Asia viene el mediterraneo
europeísmo el chejo que creo es que me burlo
el cruce que el campo al lago i que
Giorgia Meloni dijo la forma que
llegarán a respetar al chef Max pruébalos
es eso
Vamos a crear un cambiador de nivel interno
solo una declaración sobre el tema de la migración
ideas y
themasthetic con el que estoy relacionado
[Música]
configuremos el desarrollo
y derechos
etc.
Giulio que tenia que pasar llegamos con
historias terrorificas destà comunitarios
no hay minoria un poco relativo e
Giulia Meloni preguntó esto por un tiempo.
Giorgia Meloni nos superllena un poco
en el reverso de la campaña sustituta
principal
clásico de la
derecha de la Venecia Moderna Radical e
por encima de la defensa las Fronteras e
de la identidad del pueblo italiano
soy cue el sol el tiburon y tu sabes
si le prendió fuego pero si seguramente allí
migración al proponer un bloqueo naval
para evitar y preguntó
bote
esperanzas que llega al África de
Medio Oriente la Mariolina del tiburón
y mantén presionado el derecho para aplicar
digamos que el rey fue claro y con
Este bloqueo naval propone bloqueará el
hundirte serás posible porque
técnicamente por al menos un nivel
de apariencia
es muy complicado desde el otro lado
despertando Mmm pulso tanto a
fuera de Lissa Sion de las fronteras
Europeas con la creación de hotspots en
los brotes africanos de spaises crean un
filtro gammorde de entrada exterior
del Jazz del fuera del territorio
Más claro africano que europeo
Obviamente con los espacios de la
referencia No realmente un poco con el
lógica del muro entre Piano y el po il
resto e assido munii sol enfático tema
incómodo reconocer a la familia como única
familia legítima allí quedándose con éste
puede una sombra un mouer y si tiene
expresado se deforma bastante y
tema contundente constante sobre el cual si
esencialmente estar en contra del aborto
también cumplirá la forma
paradar alla mujeres arriba alternativa
la posición de Giorgia Meloni con
en comparación con La gherra enocrania podemos
solo se que te das cuenta con el
presidente y Blair Putin y la pobreza a
cambiamos el rombo vemos que el
Posición italiana con el
quimioterapias y ahora mismo esto tiene
comentado
ahora cual es la politica que eres
días de Italia pero realmente
la expectativa
Invasión y Ucrania Putin ambos muy y
un personal digamos con que inu
fiesta europea digamos que si fue toma
relación si juega melones durante la
campaña y ahí tengo un proceso joven
de oro y suplicando atención a
capital si europeo es el reemplazo
si europeo se representa a sí mismo de todos modos
un líder rendido moverá la cosa que Noah
en realidad
Sin embargo Pino que en cuanto a
video política exterior el cruce
que aguanta y el pais y no creo que tenga
cambio en relación con la posición
Italia es el viejo conflicto ruso
y yo en este limite nos claros nella
posición
Berlusconi que
sintomar position sprooutino
obviamente tratado de
impuro es
posición de maslanda relativa a
sanción
alla Busca de un proceso del pase viene
poner Giorgia Meloni perentorio muy
Clara diciendo que Italia no es
ahora moverá la pantalla actual
julio
y Matteo Salvini te aseguro que puede ser
con victoria de meloni Ivan Aversi
de incógnito Italia realmente melones Sí
felicidades pobrecito
La política italiana y sí inevitable Eso es
Y
su necio que has diferenciado algunas
importante dentro de la coalición de
Recia y entran los Hermanos de Italia
y la liga Salvini de Forza Italia
Berlusconi y Massimo económico tanto en
tema de la subasta de política exterior que estábamos
juntos goinglita y soportado
en realidad causa fractura”, de la
tornado y claro de pie el resultado
circunscripción de los Hermanos de Italia que ha
sobreexposición al ganado Salis vino de
región de Italia hasta en el norte es una
tradicionalmente rico y digamos
Serkans en la noche de LaLiga dona la Liga
Históricamente, North siempre ha sostenido
se quejó
En cualquier caso, me había ido antes, ahora
claramente les da
controles sobre la coalición